hello my name is michael mann i'm a
thoracic surgeon from the University of
California at San Francisco and the
director of our cardiothoracic
translational research laboratory there
today we'll be talking about a new
molecular prognostic technology that
will actually provide new avenues
hopefully to improve the care and maybe
even improve the outcomes of our
patients with early stage non squamous
non-small cell lung cancer of course
it's my duty to disclose at the outside
of this talk that I do work for Life
Technologies Corporation as a clinical
consultant and I have been one of the
key people involved in the development
of this technology now I'd like to focus
your attention this morning on several
objectives for this talk and perhaps the
most important aspect of what we'll be
discussing today is that not only do we
have a real burning need for better
prognostic information in improving the
management of our early stage non-small
cell lung cancer patients but there
actually is a way to incorporate this
new information into our management
decisions in a very rational and well
supported way so we'll be talking about
that need and we'll be talking about the
immediate clinical utility of using that
new prognostic differentiation of risk
of death among stage 1 and stage 2
non-small cell lung cancer patients of
course in the course of this talk will
also give you some of the details of the
development of a well-validated
multigene prognostic essay that can
confidently be used to help guide
decisions for patients early after
operation for non-small cell lung cancer
now the dilemma facing clinicians who
are trying to manage patients with early
stage lung cancer really stems from some
of the limits of the basic tools that we
use
every day in managing our practices and
of course the vast majority of our
decisions in management with regard to
our non small-cell patients is based on
the prognostic information from
traditional tnm staging and we were very
pleased several years ago to be able to
introduce into our practices the use of
a new staging system based on more
recent more modern data called from a
large international database but even
after the introduction of this new
seventh edition of ajcc staging for
non-small-cell lung cancer in 2009 were
still faced with a very large problem
even patients with stage 1 and stage 2
disease represent a very heterogeneous
mix of some patients who have been cured
by surgery alone and therefore need no
further intervention with a large
minority in some cases majority of
patients who despite a stage 1 or stage
2 designation by the TNM system must
Harbor undetectable maybe even micro
metastatic disease even when they're
undergoing an operation and the reason
we know that is because thirty to
forty-five percent of stage 1 patients
and as many as seventy percent
sixty-five to seventy percent of
patients with stage 2 disease are going
to relapse even after so-called complete
resection so that metastatic disease is
present in these early stage patients if
you will maybe represent a problem of
under staging and yet we have no way to
really better identify or discriminate
among those stage 1 and stage 2 patients
so that we can focus our attention at
mollifying or modifying the risk that
those patients face of early relapse and
death within five years from the very
same disease that we're hoping to cure
in the operating room so again the poor
outcomes that we're still suffering with
in lung cancer of course are contributed
from other factors coma
these are older patients they are very
often smokers and of course are
encumbered with all of those other
health-related problems but the major
culprit perhaps as high as 90 percent of
the deaths early within five years after
presumptive curative surgery for
non-small cell lung cancer are due to
recurrence of the disease and that is
most often involving metastatic disease
at a remote location outside of the loan
so these patients are harboring disease
that we just cannot detect based on our
conventional methods of imaging and and
tnm staging devices now I want to just
remind you of a very stark and daunting
fact which is that stage one really
means something very different for lung
cancer patients compared to patients
with other common solid tumors such as
breast and colon cancer a stage one
patient with those other tumors is
facing a ninety percent or better chance
of long-term survival with just surgery
alone contrast that to a thirty to
forty-five percent mortality within five
years from lung cancer and you realize
that we're just not doing an adequate
job of differentiating patients who've
been cured by surgery with lung cancer
and those who must Harbor metastatic
disease and unfortunately are destined
for recurrence and early death so there
is an unmet need for more precise better
differentiation based on prognosis in
early-stage lung cancer and
unfortunately that situation has not
changed in recent years even with the
advent of our new staging system these
patients who are dying are often dine
with metastatic disease now the question
is even if we were able to identify
those patients and know which patients
truly were not really meeting a quote
unquote early-stage designation is there
something we could do to improve the
outcome for those patients all right I
would I would suggest that there is
something we can do first of all stage 2
non-small cell lung cancer on the
there is a very firm recommendation that
these patients certainly those beyond
stage 2a and most of the patients in
stage 2a themselves with nodal disease
there is a firm recommendation for
adjuvant chemotherapy and that's based
on at least three large-scale
prospective randomized studies done over
the past decade that have indicated a
survival benefit to these patients with
adjuvant chemotherapy that survival
benefit has been demonstrated in stage 2
disease and also in stage 3 a disease
now even though there is this very firm
recommendation there are a lot of
patients who choose to forgo that
intervention early after operation why
is that first of all these patients have
undergone a very morbid often painful
operation even done in a minimally
invasive setting there's certainly a lot
of early postoperative issues that they
need to deal with and remember these are
largely elderly patients the average age
of diagnosis and non-small cell lung
cancer is about 70 years old so these
patients have comorbidities they've
gotten through a big operation they're
not very enthusiastic about another
morbid course of therapy involving a
platinum based doublet but there's
another factor as well the studies that
we have to convince the patients that
they will derive a benefit from this
morbid therapy again have taken all
comers all stage 2 patients which
represents 52 maybe sixty-five percent
of patients who do Harbor metastatic
disease but the rest of those patients
have been cured by their surgery alone
so the absolute benefit to that entire
group has been relatively small in part
because when we've studied those
patients in these prospective studies we
haven't been able to focus in on the
patients who are truly at the highest
risk for early relapse through
undetected metastatic disease so
unfortunately the statistics were able
to offer these
stage 2 patients that that there's about
a five to fifteen percent absolute
increase in survival and oftentimes
that's just not enough to motivate these
patients since they don't know are they
in a very high risk population or are
they among the stage two patients who've
been cured by surgery now we also know
from those studies that as a patient's
stage goes up they go up from stage two
to 3a or in these studies from 1b to
stage two they tend to get an increased
degree of benefit of the chemotherapy
now stage remember is just an indicator
of prognosis the entire staging system
is just a prognostic system that's been
derived from retrospective data so when
these patients prognosis gets worse the
degree of benefit that they wrote that
they derive from a treatment that would
address that high risk of disease gets
better but again there's no way to
identify stage two patients who are at
the highest risk of disease so there's
no way to motivate the patients who will
derive the most benefit and guide them
toward the therapy now it's not just the
patients who are hesitant very often we
as clinicians are somewhat conflicted we
see a patient with a lot of morbidities
and we're not sure if they really will
derive enough benefit from the
chemotherapy not knowing their exact
risk in order to justify the risks
associated with that chemotherapy well
if we had better differentiation of risk
even within stage two and we could
identify the patients who are at the
highest risk of death within five years
among stage two patients not only would
clinicians know that they really need to
target those patients for it was likely
more effective intervention but the
patient's themselves would know that at
least the decision they're making is
based on a better understanding of their
true clinical condition now let's turn
our attention to stage one okay there
may be a way to use better prognostic
information in refining clinical
decision-making among stage two patients
where we know that there's a benefit
from adjuvant chemotherapy the dilemma
for stage 1 patients is that the
randomized prospective studies that have
been done in the pan
have not yet given us concrete
definitive evidence that there is a
survival benefit to these patients from
adjuvant chemotherapy but remember we're
talking about a heterogeneous population
now the majority of which have been
cured by surgery so there's a very high
bar to be reached by these prospective
studies which in general have not
enrolled very large numbers of stage 1
patients but there's something else
that's very important to remember about
our recommendations for these patients
even the baseline default level of
evidence for current nccn guidelines if
you look in the small print is level 2a
we'll get to that later on the next
slide in other words even the NCCN is
recognizing that we can't always rely
and depend only on prospective
randomized data to guide every decision
for a daunting clinical challenge like
non-small cell lung cancer where the
stakes are so high for so many patients
there are in instances in which we have
to use the best clinical information we
have available to guide the best
possible decisions for each patient so
based on that understanding that
underlying conceptual framework for
these recommendations the NCCN has gone
ahead and made a level 2b recommendation
which again is a consensus
recommendation even in the absence of
prospective randomized data that
high-risk stage 1 patients ought to
undergo adjuvant chemotherapy why
because high-risk stage one patient's
phase a fifty percent or perhaps even
greater chance of death within five
years from recurrence of their disease
and that's just too darn high for us to
allow these patients to go untreated
when we know that adjuvant chemotherapy
can increase the chance of survival with
patients who have micro metastatic
disease let's think about that for a
moment from our perspective studies in
stage two and stage 38 patients we know
that long-term survival is improved with
the application of adjuvant chemotherapy
after surgery that means that the
patients must have harbored metastatic
disease again that was undetectable but
their long-term survival implies that
that that level of micro metastatic
disease can actually be eradicated by
chemotherapy in the adjuvant setting now
that's revolutionary because when we
think of chemotherapy in late stage lung
cancer we very rarely if ever think
about eradicated the disease or
achieving cure so treating early
postoperative quote-unquote undetectable
or a cult metastatic disease may
actually be a different entity from
treating large macroscopic detectable
metastatic disease in the late stage it
means that we actually have an attempt
to achieve chemo therapeutic cure for
these patients and that's an enormous
opportunity so the NCCN has taken that
knowledge and that understanding albeit
from clinical trials in a slightly
different setting and they've said well
stage 1 patients also very often harbour
occult metastatic disease and since that
metastatic disease is not likely to be
any more challenging than the micro
metastatic disease of stage 2 patients
who we also think by staging have
localized disease there's no reason to
expect that that occult disease in stage
one would be any less amenable to
treatment or even eradication then stage
2 or stage 3 8 patients and so nccn has
said find the patients in stage 1 that
are at the highest risk and go ahead and
treat them with adjuvant chemotherapy
well how do you find stage 1 patients at
highest risk if you're only left with
conventional means and traditional tnm
staging of course you're going to focus
your attention on stage 1 be by
definition stage 1 be patients are at a
higher risk in stage 1a but since stage
1 be patients have not been found as an
entire group to benefit from adjuvant
chemotherapy and prospective studies
nccn goes up further and says among
stage won't be patients higher risk on
stage 1a add another group of criteria
that we think are associated with poor
prognosis so there are six criteria all
but one of which have never actually
been associated
with a benefit from chemotherapy but
they say use these criteria to find the
highest risk stage when patients and go
ahead and treat them with adjuvant
chemotherapy even though there's no real
large-scale validation that those high
risk criteria truly identify the
patients at highest risk alright we've
talked already about the fact that the
default level of support for nccn
guidelines for non-small-cell lung
cancer is level 2 aie no prospective
randomized data no question that this is
a lower level of evidence but it still
may be the best information we have
available to synthesize into a treatment
strategy for patients who are facing a
very very challenging clinical situation
in a very high risk of death and rather
leave those patients alone with no
intervention that could potentially save
their lives we now every day of our
clinical practices are facing a
difficult decision in which we need to
take this best available information and
make a strategy for each individual
patient well there's rarely been an
instance in clinical medicine where
better information has not led to better
decisions and better outcomes and so
here we really see an even more stark
need for better differentiation of risk
and better prognostic information among
these early stage lung cancer patients
to guide better decisions which may
actually end up saving some of their
lives well if we've convinced ourselves
that there's a need for better risk
discrimination and better prognostic
information in early-stage non-small
cell lung cancer how have we done so far
in meeting this this unmet need well
we've learned from breast cancer and
other clinical situations that a genetic
profiling of tumor tissue can actually
add very valid and very reliable and
meaningful prognostic information to the
clinical assessment of our patients in
fact in breast cancer it's become the
standard of care to get for certain
populations of early stage patients a
genetic expression profile that then
guides therapeutic decisions so many
researchers across the globe have looked
over the past decade for a similar type
of
netic expression signature and early
stage lung cancer that could be used to
fill the same unmet clinical need now
what I'd like to point out is that
although there have been 15 or more of
the studies published over the last
decade including one from our own
research group of six or seven years ago
these studies have depended on frozen
tissue that's been dropped into liquid
nitrogen in the operating room and most
of these studies have relied on
microarray technology in order to
develop a gene expression profile now
those are very effective tools in the
research setting but they're not very
practical for going forward into a
clinical application that can be used in
widespread clinical practice it's not
very convenient nor realistic to expect
surgeons across the country or across
the world to begin a practice of snap
freezing their patients tissues
microarray technology have certainly
improved and become refined but it's
still very operator dependent in many
respects and not as robust as
quantitative PCR now a more daunting
problem perhaps for these prior studies
is that they've been developed on a
medium scale in some instances but
they've never undergone very large-scale
independent blinded validation and that
includes the directors challenge project
published in 2008 in which an
independent blood and validation was
undertaken but failed to actually
validate the best algorithm that was
developed from that research in the
stage when patients in which we've
already identified are the perhaps at
greatest need for better prognostic
information and so in our program at
UCSF we decided to take on this
challenge not just of making a
prognostic gene expression signature and
early-stage non-small cell lung cancer
that clinicians could begin to rely on
but we really focused on making it
practical making it a test that can be
used for every patient that undergo
surgery and that requires using not
fresh frozen tissue but
paraffin-embedded tissues that have been
fixed in formalin now expression
profiling Jen
depends on messenger RNA and net RNA is
very delicate material and very often
degraded during this a fixation process
but it's possible to derive fragmented
RNA from these specimens and using again
modern quantitative PCR technology it's
possible to in a very reliable and
reproducible way derive expression
information from that fragmented
so-called lower quality RNA now we chose
a very large cohort of patients from
UCSF to build this essay and we decided
to depend on quantitative PCR rather
than a microarray or other technology to
develop our gene expression measurements
then we went through a very rigorous
process of statistical analysis in which
we actually limited the ability of our
algorithm to separate high and low risk
patients in our training cohort of UCSF
patients so that the algorithm would not
be quote unquote over fitted to the
idiosyncrasies of that training
population but would be more likely to
work effectively in identifying high and
low risk patients in the real world
outside of this UCSF cohort then we
turned to our colleagues in the realm of
lung cancer to help us undertake
independent blinded validations on a
large scale and we look to two sources
we turn to our colleagues across San
Francisco Bay in the Kaiser Northern
California research program they have in
the past undertaken very important
independent validations of other similar
studies and we asked them to look at
close to 500 of their early stage lung
cancer patients to see if this assay did
in fact successfully differentiate high
and low risk patients we also turned
across the Pacific Ocean to colleagues
of ours in the China clinical trials
consortium and asked them on an even
larger scale to test this algorithm
independently in a blinded fashion among
their patients now again the assay
itself involves measurement of
expression of specific genes from among
lung cancer
specimens that have already been fixed
in formalin and processed into paraffin
so the assay involves getting that RNA
out of those paraffin blocks and
paraffin sections and then undertaking a
very specific refined quantitative
real-time PCR methodology so that we
very reliably measure the expression of
those genes then we apply the algorithm
and what we end up with is a risk score
that it gets try fer cated into patients
with high risk of recurrence
intermediate risk of recurrence or low
risk of death within five years after
surgery and let me refine that it's not
actually a recurrence score but a risk
of death score within five years after
surgery now those two large-scale
blinded international validation studies
were brought together in one publication
that was released and published in the
lancet in March of 2012 that validation
involved a large cadre of our colleagues
from around the world and a large
representation of institutions not just
in the United States but in China where
they really have an outstanding level of
clinical excellence in the delivery of
lung cancer care and just to tell you a
little bit more about this China
clinical trials consortium it was
initially built with leading
institutions in the major cities along
the eastern seaboard of China and has
since then expanded out to involve
leading clinical centers in other parts
of China where the delivery of clinical
care is at the highest level of
international standards and where this
new consortium has brought in the
highest level of global research
standards to make sure that the data are
as believable and as reliable as those
from our colleagues in the Kaiser
Northern California Department of
research what about the data well these
two graphs really tell an important
story on the left side you see the
survival curves of low intermediate and
high risk patients in the China cohort
and that represented patients in stages
one through three
on the right you see the graph of
survival among again low intermediate
and high risk patients in the Kaiser
Northern California cohort those
patients were all stage one patients
from from their system of hospitals in
Northern California now one thing I do
want to emphasize is that this assay was
developed not for all histologies of
non-small cell lung cancer but
specifically for non swaim asst
non-small-cell why is that squamous cell
carcinoma of the lung has clearly been
identified to be a different biological
entity from the non squamous varieties
that we encounter how do we know that
well there are a number of pieces of
evidence molecular studies certainly
have shown a very difference in
biological activity of these tumor cells
but even at the clinical level we know
that there are therapies that will work
for adenocarcinoma that just are not as
effective in squamous cell carcinoma and
vice versa so that we know clinically
that these are two different entities
and that certainly was borne out in the
research laboratory so rather than
trying to force these entities to into
one genetic algorithm that wasn't really
well-suited for either we chose to
refine this genetic expression profile
for patients with a more uniform disease
I enon squamous non-small cell lung
cancer now you can see the separation of
the survival curves in both of these
cohorts are very similar you see of
course slightly better overall survival
for the stage one patients and Kaiser
compared to the mix of stages one
through three a in the China cohort but
the separation and the validation of the
algorithm are really quite striking in
their similarity between these two
populations to the best of our knowledge
this is one of the first demonstrations
that the genetic activity of non-small
cell lung cancer is a relatively uniform
entity whether you're taking a
population with one genetic background
from Northern California or a very
different genetic background of patients
in China and applying one genetic test
to both of those populations
now it's it's been set up as a challenge
to these types of gene expression
algorithms that they be able to do
better than just classical tnm staging
and differentiating high and low risk
patients one of the ways that you test
that is by looking within each stage to
see whether or not the algorithm
separates stage 1 stage 2 and maybe even
stage 3 patients with different levels
of disease and this algorithm and this
test met this challenge quite well of
course in in the Kaiser population we
were only dealing with stage 1 patients
but in the China cohort we had stage 1
and stage 2 patients that we could look
at independently and you can see here
that in these two graphs that the that
these genetic expression tests truly
separated out stage 1 patients at
different levels of risk and stage two
patients at levels of risk and even
though it's not shown in this slide we
saw the same good separation but very
very tiny p values among stage 3a
patients as well now any program like
this is going to want to look at
multivariate analysis and sure enough
there was a very profound increase in
the hazard ratio associated with a high
risk score from this genetic expression
test and although the prince is a little
bit smaller you can go to the lancet
publication to see more of the details
even in multivariate analysis when we
were able to look at all the traditional
risk factors among stage when patients
that have been associated with poor
prognosis the hazard ratio for the high
risk test adjusted for all those factors
remained above two indicating a very
high correlation of this assay with
patient outcome even among stage 1
patients even considering the size of
the tumor which up until now is one of
our best prognostic indicators now of
course a similar univariate and
multivariate analysis was performed in
the China population and we saw very
similar results but this time because we
had a mixed population of stages 1 2 and
3 patients were able to adjust the
hazard ratio analysis
even for stage and even adjusting for
stage we see a very significant very
substantial increase in the hazard ratio
associated just with a high risk score
from this gene profiling assay no
clinical covariant information
introduced this is all based on a gene
expression profile reflecting the
molecular biology of the tumor now one
other thing I'd like to point out it at
this juncture is that this looks like
pretty good validation data but you
might think is this really comparable to
our validation of staging which guides
most of our clinical decisions certainly
in non-small cell lung cancer well think
about it 500 patients in Kaiser a
thousand patients in the China
consortium cohort that's roughly 1,500
patients even the new tnm staging system
for Stage one was validated only on
about 2,200 stage 1 patients so we're
talking about a similar scale of
validation for this molecular prognostic
assay compared to the validation even of
our new important tnm staging system so
these are data that a clinician can
really rely on in terms of inputting
more information into difficult clinical
decisions and if we think about a direct
comparison of this prognostic assay with
the prognostic information that's
available from conventional criteria and
especially from tnm staging we can look
to statistical methods that have
underscored the true improvement in
prognostic information that this type of
molecular analysis has provided I
particularly want to focus your
attention on the graph on the right side
of the screen this is an oreck analysis
which represents the area underneath the
receiver operating curve which is one of
the most reliable most relied upon
methods for comparing two prognostic
tools now remember these are not
diagnostic tools and therefore there's
no way to apply a positive or negative
predictive value in comparing the tools
instead they're stochastic or
probabilistic tools assigning each
patient a degree of risk and so we need
to use these slightly more sophisticated
it's statistical tools to compare them
directly now remember nccn guidelines
have told clinicians look stage 1
patients are facing facing a thirty to
forty-five percent chance of death and
among those patients are high-risk
patients for whom the risk of death is
even worse nccn has said find those
patients and treat them with an adjuvant
chemotherapy that might save their lives
well we compared directly those nccn
high risk criteria that they have
suggested in their guidelines to the
differentiation of risk that's possible
now with this molecular expression
profile si and that increase in the dark
blue area under the receiver operating
curve shows a dramatic improvement in
prognostication that means that you're
now better able much better able and
more reliably able to identify high-risk
patients among stage one better than
current nccn suggested criteria which
means you could carry out that existing
recommendation from the NCCN to treat
high-risk patients now with much more
reliable prognostic information so that
you know you're really finding the
highest risk stage when patients and
offering them an intervention that that
may save their lives now finally I'd
like just like to focus your attention
on some even more recent data that were
published late last fall in JAMA in
which we focused on a subpopulation of
this large international cohort that not
only had stage 1 disease but had t1a
tumors the very smallest tumors
according to our staging system less
than two centimeters in diameter node-
patients who we believe have the best
possible prognosis among resected lung
cancer patients patients whom we would
never consider offering adjuvant
chemotherapy but remember 25% of those
patients are going to be dead most of
them from lung cancer within five years
of surgery so obviously conventional
criteria and traditional staging are not
doing a good enough job of identifying
only those patients who have been cured
by surgery and separating out ones that
are more likely to have metastatic
disease that is it
exactly where this genetic assay can
come into play we apply the ass eight of
these patients and we were able to
identify high-risk patients for whom the
five-year survival was no better than
fifty percent so even among these
patients with t1 a small tumors whom we
believed are cured in the operating room
this genetic assay is able to identify
those patients with a fifty percent
mortality very similar to the stage two
patients who are now firmly recommended
to undergo adjuvant chemotherapy to try
to mollify that risk of death and this
was just not a tiny sliver of the
overall population of T when a patient's
this was a full third of those t1a
patients that are found to be at fifty
percent chance of death within five
years all right what have we gone over
this morning I think we've convinced
ourselves again that there's a real need
for better prognostic information than
conventional criteria and tnm staging
are able to provide in order to guide
more refined clinical strategic
decisions for our patients with
early-stage lung cancer I hope I've
convinced you that we now have available
a very robust and very reliable and very
practical assay that can be used for
just about any patient to do a better
job of risk prognostication among stage
with a non small-cell again non squamous
lung cancer now this assay is reliable
precisely because it's been
independently validated in a blinded
fashion in two of the largest
international cohorts that have ever
been assembled to study the molecular
biology of non-small cell lung cancer
for any purpose and we've actually
demonstrated through that cohort that
this multigene sa outperforms
conventional risk factors and even the
tnm staging system to identify patients
at the highest risk of death after
surgery for lung cancer and so what can
we conclude well we need to do a better
job for these patients because too many
of them are dying despite our best
attempt at operative cure we do have
evidence that we can actually eradicate
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer
how can we do that by identifying it at
its earliest stage
is in the adjuvant setting when
conventional criteria are unable to
detect the metastatic disease we get
improved long-term survival and not just
palliative prolongation of survival
which is all we tend to see in late
stage disease plus the benefit from that
chemotherapy tends to tends to increase
and be greatest among the patients who
are at highest risk therefore it really
behooves us as clinicians to go beyond
the limitations of purely prospective
randomized study data which let's face
it is very limiting to our practice and
to use the best information that's
available to us now to identify the
patients who need intervention the most
and B are likely to benefit the most
from an intervention we are already
making difficult decisions in the
management of these patients and
relegating many of these patients to
just waiting for their death sentence to
be carried out isn't there something we
can do with this better information to
make better-informed decisions at a time
when we might actually be able to
intervene impact their survival maybe
even save a few lives now again we're
talking about changing a paradigm we're
talking about eliminating just a
watchful waiting approach for these
patients at very high risk of death and
instead turning to a new type of tool a
tool that looks specifically at the
biology of an individual patients cancer
and using that better more refined
discriminatory prognostic information to
say well this patient really is at high
risk we really need to intervene whereas
other patients okay these patients now
we know even beyond tnm staging are at a
low risk of early death after surgery
maybe those are the patients for whom
the monitoring and the watchful waiting
is more appropriate hopefully this type
of paradigm will help us to shift
survival in non-small cell lung cancer
something that we've been trying to do
now for 30 to 40 years all of the
excitement about targeted therapies EGFR
therapies and the like have helped us
prolong survival in stage four but let's
face it very rarely have we cured a
patient with advanced either locally
advanced
are systemically advanced disease even
with the targeted therapy those patients
still die we have a chance to save more
of our early stage patients by
introducing a personalization of risk
discrimination in early stage management
that might actually increase their
survival now we UCSF and many of our
colleagues across the globe are already
engaged in a longer-term prospective
randomized study that will specifically
attack this question of how much can we
improve the survival of high-risk stage
1 patients by applying adjuvant
chemotherapy specifically in that sub
population of patients whom we can now
identify being to be at highest risk but
remember that type of prospective
randomized study is not going to get
done overnight we're launching that
study now and we hope to have the data
available in our lifetimes and in the
lifetimes of some of our patients but
can we really just sit around and wait
for those most pristine data to be
available and ignore new data that may
already be available to help guide
decisions in the here and now finally I
wouldn't be doing justice if I didn't
more definitively acknowledge the
enormous contributions of many brilliant
and talented individuals to the
development of this technology my close
friend and colleague David J blondes who
is the leader of the thoracic oncology
program and the builder of the thoracic
oncology program at UCSF worked with me
closely to spearhead all of these
studies we benefited immensely from the
contribution of dr. johannes Kratz who's
now back out in Boston at Massachusetts
General Hospital and a wealth of other
individuals again from across the globe
who really were indispensable to the
successful completion of the research
that I was able to share with you this
morning now I understand that some of
you may have through the internet sent
some questions that I can try to address
and I'm going to ask one of my
colleagues here in the studio to see if
he can provide those questions to me so
that we can have more of an interactive
discussion this morning I also
understand that
there may be a chat room available to us
immediately after this talk is finished
if there's additional questions that you
might have which you'd like to address
in a written format okay thank you dr.
Mann for a great discussion we've got
one question coming in which is first
how can I use the information from the
preventing essay to guide treatment
decisions if there is no prospective
randomized data indicating a benefit of
chemotherapy in stage 1 patients okay
thank you very much again ah not an
uncommon question people in the world of
oncology are used to having very
evidence-based means for guiding their
decision treat treatment that their
decision trees especially when the
treatment involves a chemotherapy that
by nature is very morbid and may even
have mortality associated with that
intervention itself and we tend to think
in limited terms you know how could I
possibly relegate my patient to a very
morbid therapy without very definitive
prospectively randomized data to guide
that intervention well as I've tried to
address through the talk we're making
that difficult decision whether we want
to or not we are looking at patients who
have a fifty percent or greater chance
of death from a disease that we know
does have an effective treatment what's
limited or our tools identify those
patients now we have better tools to
provide better prognostic information in
just about every aspect of medicine and
oncology is no exception we are never
really dealing with every individual
patient a context that has been
documented in a prospective randomized
study prospective randomized studies
always have very rigid inclusion and
exclusion criteria to guide us toward a
very specific patient population very
often the patient in our office does not
meet all of those criteria but what we
do is we extrapolate the best possible
information from what's available
applied to this
patience individual clinical scenario
well albeit we're talking about perhaps
a larger scale of patients now we're
talking thinking about all of stage one
but there's a very high percentage of
those stage one patients that we can now
identify as being a very high risk of
death even after complete resection of
their lung tumors and is it ethical to
withhold a potentially life-saving
intervention when we know these patients
are a very high risk of death and have a
very reasonable chance of benefit from
an intervention even though we haven't
yet completed the prospective randomized
study targeting specifically those
high-risk patients that would give an
opportunity for definitive prospective
randomized data or undertaking that
study but in the interim is it really
ethical to leave those patients without
any intervention when there isn't an
unknown intervention that has a very
reasonable supportive body of evidence
that these patients are likely to
benefit and when we talk about benefit
we're talking about potentially saving
their lives thank you the next question
comes in and it's around what is the
significance of the intermediate risk
score very good question we chose to try
for Kate the risk scores when we develop
this assay and its clinical application
rather than just high and low risk
patients to look at high intermediate
and low-risk patients we realize that
clinicians really need to know who among
their early stage patients who among
those stage want patients who among
those stage two patients are really the
patients at highest risk of death
because those are the patients where the
difficult decisions become less
difficult if we could identify the
patients who are really facing a very
poor prognosis a very high chance of
5-year mortality those are patients that
are very are much more likely to benefit
in in very severe need of that
prognostic information in order to make
a truly informed decision so we chose to
try fer Kate the data so that we had a
lot higher level of confidence that
patients whom were identifying as high
risk of death are really different
patients from those who were calling low
risk of death and that intermediate
group gives
that buffer to have an even higher
degree of confidence that high-risk
patients are truly highest risk and
low-risk patients truly have the lowest
risk of those that we can identify with
this assay now the intermediate patients
or patients too and they need help and
they need to make their own decisions We
certainly have no less information than
we did before running the assay and
perhaps now we have a little bit of more
information to guide those decisions as
well because we know those patients are
not in the highest risk group granted
they're not in the lowest risk group
either but that is meaningful
information that we didn't have before
and that information needs to be
funneled into the to the most informed
decision possible for all of those
patients I think a follow-up to that is
does the assay incorporate any clinical
covariance or other clinical data and
its determination of risk so as I
mentioned briefly in discussing the data
from our publications the algorithm and
the risk score generated by this test
depend entirely on the genetic
expression data that we derived from the
from the patient's tumor tissue itself
so we are not incorporating any clinical
covariates into that decision making one
benefit of that approach is that it's
truly complementary information to
traditional a risk assessment and
conventional tnm staging we're not
introducing any of that information into
the assignment of risk based on the
molecular profile it also eliminates any
confounding of that information in the
determination determination of risk
that's truly based on the biology of the
tumor itself because we think the
benefit of this test is that it is
introducing a biological approach to
understanding the tumor that will give
us the best handle on knowing whether
that tumor is likely to have spread or
whether that tumor is perhaps more
likely to have been cured by a
presumably complete resection in the
operating room now something else that
I'd like to emphasize here is that
these data really can be used to to add
additional information to all of that
clinical covariate information that we
already have and yet we believe that
it's based on the natural course of the
tumors evolution from its earliest
phases of perhaps pre invasiveness or
micro invasiveness to full-blown
metastasis and late stage disease that's
in contrast to other types of genetic
based information of which we now have
an abundance in lung cancer where we're
looking primarily at genetic mutations
that may have predisposed the tissue and
predisposed the patient to developing a
lung cancer the most obvious examples of
course are EGFR mutation and alch
translocation in those instances there
is a genetic background within the cells
whether it's acquired or inherited that
we believe has predisposed those cells
those cells to enter a pathway toward
malignancy and those tumors therefore
may have an inherent susceptibility to
various types of interventions and maybe
even have a natural history that
somewhat divergent from tumors that
don't have those specific mutations but
we're not focused on mutations in this
particular assay this is a gene
expression profile which means it's
looking really at the behavior of the
tumor not at its genetic origins and
it's going across the board it's not
focused on a specific subtype of tumors
that have perhaps been derived from up
specific genetic mutations it's really
looking at the biology of the tumor and
quite likely at the biology of the
patient's response to the tumor the
genes that we've chosen to compose this
assay were not picked just by rational
design we actually let the statistics
guide our selection of these genes we
started with about 200 genes that were
known to be involved
cancer and in lung cancer specifically
and through preliminary studies we hone
that down first to about 60 genes which
we studied more intensely and then
finally a set of 11 genes that the
outcomes of the patients told us were
associated with more prognostic
information and we let the tumor tissues
guide the selection of those genes not
what we believe to be our knowledge
about lung cancer based on first
principles so some of these genes are
related to the EGFR pathway some of
these genes are related to developmental
signaling pathways such as the wint
pathway which is almost certainly
playing a large role in the evolution of
these cancers but some of these genes
are related to metabolism and some of
these genes are even more related to the
immune response within the tissues to
the tumor and so we're really getting a
landscape or a cross-section of the
tumor biology and the patient's
biological response to the tumor that's
helping us to understand where in the in
the evolution of this individual
patient's disease did this tumor sit
when it was resected from the lung so
based on all of that information about
the biology of the tumor independent of
clinical covariance were able to say
okay this tumor seems to be here on its
progression towards almost inevitable
metastasis had it been left alone is it
more or less likely to have already
spread outside of the confines of the
lung and outside of the confines of the
resection specimen and does that patient
therefore likely stand to benefit from
further intervention I think we have one
final question coming in is person is
interested in the biochemical
correlation and cancers in general and
specifics an early stage are there such
prognostic correlations very important
what we've learned over the past decade
or two is that there is definitely a
correlation between the molecular
biology of the tumor at any given point
in time and the overall prognosis for
that tumor in terms
of its likelihood of being associated
with metastatic disease and a poor
outcome I mentioned earlier the
experience in the realm of breast cancer
we're very similar expression profile
testing was introduced nearly a decade
ago and has become the standard of care
for at least certain early stage breast
cancer patients who are often being told
that they're at a very low risk of
recurrence and often are told they can
safely forgo adjuvant chemotherapy so we
have examples from a number of different
tumor types in which we've documented
fairly well on a large scale now that
the molecular activity of the tumor is
very closely related with the the
outcome for the patient and that almost
certainly is connected through a better
understanding of the evolution of that
individual tumor along this progression
toward eventual metastatic disease can
we make a lot of assumptions about the
molecular biology of tumors based on
less less well-developed early studies
no of course not we need to rely on
large scale validation to understand the
true correlations between discoveries in
the molecular realm and what's going on
especially with early stage patients
whom we hope have a better outcome down
the road but one thing we know is that
we need to do better than just looking
at traditional 17th century technology
in order to understand the prognosis for
these patients because they're facing
real challenges and there are
interventions that we have to consider
in order to improve their likelihood of
survival that looks like I don't see any
more questions thank you dr. Mann for
answering those so thoroughly I don't
see any additional questions perhaps
maybe the chat room if someone has
questions they may
s they're great well I'd like to thank
everybody for their attention I hope
this was somewhat informative again we
can refer you to the lancet and jam of
publications we have additional
publications coming down the line and we
hope to intrigue you even further in a
number of years with data from our
prospective randomized study again thank
you very much
you